allez là ni là pour parler plus
sérieusement une nouvelle série arrive
sur tf1 et ça risque de faire beaucoup
de bruit c'est pourquoi c'est une
affaire français il s'agit d'une fiction
sur la sphère du petit grégory cette
triste affaire de ce petit garçon
retrouvé mort dans la vologne attaché
ligoté et c'est en 1984 regardez la
bande-annonce et puis on en parle après
[Musique]
c'est des gens la famille
très proche
cette affaire a pris une dimension
médiatique considérable
tous jouent avec nous les journalistes
c'est ça la presse accusée d'avoir tué
mon enfant
une affaire française la nouvelle
création tf1 lundi à 21h05
[Musique]
qui va regarder gila vous dites non déjà
comment peut-on scénarisé c'était
rejouer avec un drame en plus ça n'a pas
été la première fois résolu cette
affaire non mais je le dis à chaque fois
les époux villemin n'avait même pas été
prévenus d'ailleurs ils savent et c'est
le domaine public
je parle de la morale par élégance et
par morales aurait pu les prévenir lui
qui met plus que ça c'est une affaire
qui n'est pas réglé il ya encore une
instruction il ya encore des feuillets
s'il a tué absolument essayer des juges
travaillent sur le dossier je trouve que
c'est proprement scandaleux mois et que
ces foulées aux pieds la mémoire du
petit grégory de faire à la fin
alors moi je suis pas maître du coup
merde
tous d'accord tu mets n'ont donc tu vas
pas mais moi je sais pas quand est ce
que c'est une affaire qui est justement
parce qu'elle n'est pas résolu me
fatigue maintenant maintenant quand on
s'avance ont le droit de l'adopter
pardon ça a déjà été fait en fiction
celle ci les acteurs sont absolument
prodigieux et ça colle au documentaire
de netflix est vraiment très très proche
de la réalité ça a été fait récemment un
documentaire parce que j'étais avec un
réseau immense des acteurs sont le plus
prodigieux j'ai jamais vu jumelles avait
trouvé en avant mais en revanche oui une
histoire non résolus pardon mais le
mangement détourne enfin enfin un prime
de ce nom une nouveauté digne de saumon
pour la rentrée de tf1 ce que là pour
l'instant ça se résume à koh lanta lé
mardi gameloft à nantes etc à l'est
c'est une fiction française et un
casting qui est mortelle la sphère elle
passionne les français le documentaire
sur netflix il a cartonné je suis sûr ça
a marché tout est réuni pour que ça
marche et ça c'est digne de tf1 et ça va
cartonner chenaf d'aller regarder alors
moi je vais regarder parce que si je
suis amené à revenir dans cette émission
j'imagine qu'on va en parler je veux
savoir de quoi on parle
voilà non non je ne sais pas en fait je
suis un peu je suis partagé je suis pas
trop d'accord avec isabelle le fait
qu'ils les acteurs très connus comme ça
est très populaire moi je pense que ça
va être bizarre ça va être bizarre parce
qu'on s'attend pas à voir un michaël
youn ou un gérard jugnot écoles
devraient des registres vraiment comme
ça très prenante et puis neuf voilà une
histoire vraie quelques mois je suis je
sais pas je suis partagé je vais
regarder mais justement avant de me
prononcer je pense que je sais pas je
suis un peu comme gîte d'abord il ya eu
une multitude de documentaires satisfont
la connais par coeur on ne connaît pas
dénouement devant cantona tient une
enquête policière voilà qui est pas
bouclé qu'on connaît par coeur on a tout
vu tout entendu je trouve que ça na ça
m'intéresse pas du tout après il ya un
casting sublime ah oui eh bien moi je me
demande mes mais sa date qui va parler
de l'intérêt l'instant on a interrogé
mais je me demande comment on finit donc
cette série que c'est quoi quand comment
ça finit sa fille et comme là
rien à dire s'il ya plein de suspicion
il ya là qu'un sa théorie il ya des
interrogations il ya toujours des pistes
qui sont menées je comprends même pas
que ça pas été mis à l'antenne plus
enfin mis en histoire plutôt tellement
c'est l'histoire la plus grande
levée bien sûr raymond c'est une affaire
qui a passionné les fronts à la fois
85 86 84 84 moi d'abord j'ai ça très
malin de pas avoir mis le pr nom de
gregory dans le dans le truc d'hommes
d'affaires française regardez le casting
moi pourquoi j'ai mis oui parce que
c'est que des gens que j'aime bien y'a
pas disons que j'aime par là dedans
c'est que des gens que j'aime bien c'est
que des gens qui m'ont fait rêver au
cinéma donc la chance au produit pour le
premier épisode tu es obligé d'aller tu
vas aller tu vas aller regarder si le
premier épisode il est pourri ou qu'il
émergeait tu décroches mais si le
premier épisode est bon tu vas rentrer
dans la série et puis tu vas tu va
regarder forcément moi je rejoins
guillaume ils ont faim ils ont faim
attendu sen pas là-dessus ans c'est ça
vous ne savez vraiment un coup sans
parler des prénoms tout à l'heure la une
des conséquences de ces univers s'il
n'ya pratiquement plus un enfant qui
s'appelle grégory il personne maps et
son enfant grégory maths on m'a dit on
va regarder le petit grégory a plus
personne ça prénom qui a pratiquement
disparu depuis cette affaire j'aimerais
ça vous parle et jean michel pasque avec
moi vous parlez très bien
cyril olives qui n'a pas peur le sondage
les sondages alors le sondage
grégory oui
sept
non et ça fera un carton les gens n'en
est pas si sûr
sur la deux une histoire qui a un thème
un petit peu
analog d'enfants qui disparaît avec
thibault de montalembert et petit
courrier que c'est également très fort
et c'est très regrettable que ce soit
face à connais pas mais bon montalembert
merci j'avais 10 % et 10 % oui mais
répond non tu peux pas dire ça